all right very good as the supply crisis
gets worse and rampant inflation smacks
the average consumer right in the face
and the baby maker don't look to the
commander-in-chief for answers president
biden admitting he does not have a clue
on how to fix any of those problems
watch i don't have a near-term answer
there's two things i could do i could go
on the petroleum reserve
and take out and probably reduce re
reduce the price of gas maybe
18 cents or so a gallon it's still gonna
be above three bucks the longshoremen
don't always get along with the business
folks in there
i got i have a relationship with them
and i brought them together and i said
you got to be open 24 7.
no port there was open open five days a
week 40 hours a week 24 7. they've all
agreed to it they've agreed to it
i feel like he's uh really trying to
blame the longshoremen now jesse i don't
know if that's the best move for him uh
so this was obviously a great showing by
the president tremendous performance and
he had answers for everything especially
the supply chain his answers were i
don't have any answers and that's pretty
clear he doesn't understand supply and
demand and that's clear because hunter
handles his finances he doesn't
understand in a recovery you have to
have supply meet demand so you can't be
taking away permits and pipelines and
leases so right now we're begging opec
to increase supply and opec saying screw
you we're gonna see this thing go to a
hundred dollars a barrel and we're gonna
get rich and joe can go scratch and he
doesn't have any other answers but he
campaigned on this he said we are going
to quote get rid of fossil fuels but
here's the real problem
as the inflation goes up
gas prices and oil goes up
and a weaker dollar makes gas prices and
oil go even farther up so he's going to
have high prices high inflation and and
a weak dollar and and sit around and
have no answers for this i don't think
he has a clue what to do and it's clear
so
a lot of these things to people you know
they don't they don't really understand
or want to investigate what transitory
inflation is but they know what high gas
prices are right and they know that that
bites them right in the keystoner and i
don't care if it's joe biden who's the
president or president trump or
president obama or jimmy carter it's you
have to have an answer for people who
are hurting especially when we're
getting into the holidays everything is
getting more expensive but gas is
ridiculous and he was like i don't
really have an answer in the near term
well gas prices and empty shelves also
people understand that and not during
the height of a pandemic kind of in the
midst of whatever this new normal is
that we're going to be living for
through in perpetuity
i've been talking the past few weeks on
the show about the importance of the
president at least owning what's going
on and i do think that that was an
important element of this that there was
it was him talking to a journalist
people wanted him to get interviewed he
got interviewed obviously took questions
uh from the audience i don't think that
this answer was sufficient for people
because they're still going to be saying
well
how can you you said that inflation
would be a near-term problem ron klein
also said that that doesn't seem like
it's going to be the case what are we
going to do there was one thing that i
thought was really great though in that
he explained actually the mechanics of
getting a bill passed and he talked
about like how he doesn't have the votes
to get the filibuster reform and he
talked about he actually named that
there were three holdouts which was
interesting because we usually think
it's joe manchin and kirsten cinema
kristen uh kiersten that one no brandon
um they're both kirsten
but just fell differently yeah um so i
thought that that was really interesting
but not that answer won't satisfy the
american people but i appreciate that he
took the question because they were
waiting you took it from a stacked
audience those were hand-painted people
all democrats screamed
and they were in the very end of the
show when no one's watching anymore uh
but deagon i want to show the president
he had something very interesting to say
in terms of vaccines and freedom watch
this
should police officers emergency
responders be mandated to get vaccines
and if not should they be
stay at home or let go yes and yes the
two things that concern me
one are those who just try to make this
a political issue freedom
i have the freedom to kill you
with my covey no i mean come on freedom
yeah come on freedom it's a pretty great
thing uh does he have it wrong here
degan
what a unifier what a warm person who's
really bringing the country together
uh he's clearly trapped in a bubble
surrounded by socialist sycophants
because if he he's still kind of
sticking to that oh the dirty unwashed
trump voter is the one who's
unvaccinated can we get kyrie irving on
the horn to explain to him that this is
not a
issue of race it's not even an issue of
a political persuasion number one number
two does he know that people who are
vaccinated can get coveted and so are
you know are they a danger as well to
the rest of us again it's just divisive
unnecessarily but one thing that does
unite the american people is listening
to this
person stand up there incoherent either
talking out of his ass about the
national guard helping out truckers
which can't happen which the white house
had to backtrack or actually telling the
god awful truth to the american people
these high gas prices are by design the
higher they go the more economically
sensible
electric vehicles become an alternative
energy it is by design because this is
day one killed keystone xl pipeline then
a moratorium on new drilling you have
the federal reserve and other agencies
strong-arming financial firms to not
invest in energy projects i could go on
but i want but this isn't a bug in the
system this is the feature yes
absolutely and uh one of the features of
last night was some of joe biden's
strange mannerisms including
he held up his his two fifths and just
sort of stood there what's going on with
it i know that that you went to medical
school yes uh that's called the
cornholio yeah
uh it's a uh it's it's a disorder that
you get from watching too much beavis
and butthead which i believe he was
doing during uh the 90s i believe i
think this calls for a halloween analogy
the white house the the biden white
house has now become the home that
forgot to buy halloween candy
so they're turning out the lights and
pretending they're not really there
right right mayor pete's hiding under
the bed carmel is in the closet he's out
in the backyard talking to a bush you
know there's no head on this horseman uh
and i'm i'm trying to figure out why and
the only thing i can think of is that
he's realized joe maybe he hasn't
realized this we've realized this that
the woke left contingent that's
controlling him has no solution in a
time of crisis right diversity training
pronouns racial politics you can dabble
in that stuff when the times are great
but when times aren't great they suck
and i think joe just assumed that
someone would take care of these things
but there's no one in his group
you actually do kind of need moderate
democrats and republicans to help you
out without them that you can't require
you can't expect woke swoosters to
operate heavy machinery there's nothing
in saul alinsky's playbook about
inflation you know or or or tax rates or
supply chain issues right it's only
about ridicule and race so i think
that's where we are we are i think
america is on autopilot right
doesn't it feel that way it does yeah
there's no head on that thing it's just
it's like we're we're we're
we're the government america is the
government we can do whatever we want
now if one if if everybody says screw
this we're not going to do these
mandates it could happen we can do
whatever it is they don't have an answer
to exactly that's right it's time for
the purge jesse
it's bad if they don't have an answer to
one of these things but the fact they
don't have an answer to any of them and
they're all happening at once yeah